welcome to this video playing now better
from Sweden plenty for again for a
change let's see maybe try the power off
it leads to open interesting collisions
yeah this is what they've almost all
play nowadays 96 then maybe the sharp is
moving away okay let's see what he's
doing after Bishop g5 Bishop to e6 mmm
wow what is like what exactly is right
here there are many moves the gay three
years a move so often helpful for moves
like we nee 5 and it also prepares a
further be for the right moment if I go
see 5 supported with B form let's see i
wanted to curious what he's doing now
you cannot take on c4 as i take on f6
and okay so it's giving up a move
actually the age 6 to provoke me to
capture okay now you see that Bishop
before is prevented what I'm wondering
is should I really play c5 immediately
here when it's not threatening to take
now maybe I can develop a bit a bit
first can also consider to play queen
bee three am going forward technical
solution but after that queen bee 795
looks looks a bit tricky okay should
reform I need to prevent us need to
prevent not like it was not an immediate
threat but it sort of was in the air I
want to play c5 at some stage but I
don't really see the need yet let him
commit some some more pieces okay I go
now you know should I shreya certainly
not on would be quite strange okay now
he is threatening to take so I need to
do something was so far I can tell
taking is giving him squad some pressure
on d4 so I'm advancing and now I have
four against three on the queenside + B
form is the logical follow-up yeah he
might even go g5 this is not entirely
ridiculous okay this is the idea I
wonder ever should play Bishop to b5
yeah I guess so increasing the control
over the center it wouldn't be a bigger
issue to take on c6 not at all nights
are really good in this position now I'm
threatening 95 I think this is a
positional problem for him 95 Bishop
takes d5 Bishop takes c6 would be the
play and divide the end to keep a night
against the bishop only success would be
strategically very welcome like
still play 95 can die or is it no not
really don't don't see the problem if he
takes now I will even take with the
rukon e5 threatening on d5 okay so just
move to the Queen away I could take on
c6 and play Queen to f3 one day this is
an idea yeah it's not look too bad I
have improved his pawn structure in
regards to the d5 pawn yeah this okay he
can do that but it looks very weakening
I actually thought that'd be five would
be good now as takes 95 looks like looks
like a disaster yeah g5 is weakening the
whole position enormously of course I'm
just threatening night takes c6
basically yes Wow
95 °c going to take on if I could let's
consider 94 is probably taking on if I
of him ok hmm
this still looks playable surprisingly
or you thought blacks position is
completely exploding maybe maybe that's
not so terrible I can't probably need to
take it on don't see you don't see
another move be sure now he's taking
only form of course Bishop b5 was what's
the problem okay now at least I don't
does Wow okay my g4 maybe
this is hanging what what is he doing
now aged 6 is singing rook takes Bishop
b5 wasn't so great i guess i can take
Here I am check as he needs to cover
deform I know take here that's no major
time burn it night f5 ok for night Queen
h5 check king queen of six no not
working ok I only have 40 something
second so this looks awfully risky three
nights five check check check check I'll
take the Queen that that should be
enough black resigned wow this this very
suddenly got very technical I mean ok
from a statistical point of view
blackest is completely busted here he
needs to muddy the water somehow so b5
and Bishop before and now of course he
needs to take only five I thought is
this yeah okay this is also excellent
idea that's true what he did was
actually better look at this is just a
disaster something like that here like
it's not going to survive that I'm not
even the pawn down or anything for this
brilliant position ok so this was
amazing but 94 is just winning right
yeah it is winning check no oh Queenie
for is much stronger yeah okay Queenie
for us even stronger this is just just
very nice now threatening Queen to f6 so
we cannot even take here Queen FC check
kill em okay well I went here but it
also keeps an edge I hear queen age 54
stronger yeah okay I'm not a machine 40
seconds on the clock check check check
okay let's check let's take the Queen
that sir it's enough
yeah this was a very tricky position a
TI widest already are thinking in quite
good shape I think he must do something
against this 95 or just better let's say
to it not quite sure how this is the
small force is too too much as 95 now
even this one yeah I don't know i don't
like blacks position very much it seems
like an inferior structure and I've
always get this play on the queenside
alright thanks for watching